es sind riesige wellen so wie diese die
sein beruf sind und sein leben sebastian
steudtner deutscher big wave surfer also
riesenwellen reiter ist weit dann
wirklich der atem weg wenn man ihn wie
hier in diesem wasser schluchten sieht
und doch hat er immer wieder dass mehr
im griff außer wenn ihm wie jetzt gerade
ein anderer surfer so blöd in die quere
kommt
unterwegs mit einem der besten und
waghalsigsten surfer der welt sebastian
steudtner mit einer kleinen self kamera
filmt er sich wie er den strand von
navarra an der portugiesischen
atlantikküste ab surft ein entspannter
trifft bei sonne für den mann der sonst
die größten wellen der welt surft doch
plötzlich taucht vor ihm ein anderer
surfer auf steudtner versucht noch um
ihn herum zu fahren dann schießt ein
surfbrett aus dem wasser direkt
aufstocken aus kopf zu mit einem reflex
reist steudtner seinen arm in die höhe
um den kopf zu schützen das gelingt aber
trotzdem steudtner verletzt sich schwer
ausgekugelte schlüsselbein gebrochene
rippen und gerissener muskel in nacken
und brustkorb eine einzigartige surfer
szene festgehalten von steudtner selbst
der unfall passierte im dezember nun
veröffentlichte steudtner seine
beeindruckenden aufnahmen die surf
wettkampf saison für ihn nach dem crash
erstmal dahin doch steudtner kämpft sich
seitdem zurück jeden tag reha
muskeltraining
in kürze soll es für steudtner endlich
wieder aufs wasser gehen und auf die
suche nach dem größten und
atemberaubendsten wellen der welt
und jetzt ist er live bei und sebastian
steudtner schönen guten abend hierbei
bild live wie ist das für jemanden der
die größten wellen bezwingt und dann
kommt einem als profi surfer ein anderer
surfer so blöd in die quere mich für
verständnis hat man da im ersten moment
natürlich nicht viel aber im endeffekt
ist es ein unfall gewesen hat er nicht
absichtlich gemacht von daher kann ich
jetzt schon sagen schlecht gelaufen
ja wir sehen die szenen hier gerade noch
mal schlecht gelaufen sagen sie wenn man
allerdings sieht mit welcher wucht
dieses bretter rausgeschossen kommt
könnte man auch sagen dank ihres
reflexes ist das eigentlich noch ganz
gut ausgegangen oder gott sei dank hatte
ich den reflex ich hatte ungefähr 40 km
h drauf
von daher von den kollegen wiegt sicher
8 89 kilo oder so und wenn die finden
mich am kopf zum beispiel getroffen
hätten oder dass die kante des bretts
mich am kopf oder irgendwo im gesicht
getroffen hätten wäre es glaube ich noch
unschöner gewesen
ein surfer der nicht aus wasser kann
nicht helfen kann er ist wahrscheinlich
nicht besonders gut gelaunt wie oft
hatten sie in den letzten tagen und
wochen richtig schlechte laune gut ich
hatte am anfang natürlich weiß mittel in
der saison passiert ist die panik dass
des verpasst
was gott sei nicht passiert ist als
werden tatsächlich seit dem ich diesen
unfall hatte keine großen guten wellen
hier etwas nicht normal ist also
normalerweise im dezember januar kommen
kommen die größten wellen und
dementsprechend hat sich immer so eine
einmal pro woche in panik moment will
ich die wettervorhersage gecheckt ob wo
ich dann gesehen habe gott sei dank geht
es mal das ist keine grossen wellen hat
aber ich habe mich einfach auf das
konzentriert was ich machen kann nämlich
trainieren und einfach alles zu geben um
wieder möglichst schnell zurück zu
kommen und habe da wenig wenig raum
schon irgendwelche negativen gedanken
oder viel frust oder so zugelassen man
kann das adrenalin wieder raus also wann
sind sie wieder voll einsatzfähig da in
den monsterwellen von der jury
ich bin es gestern und heute das erste
mal wieder gesagt hier in serie und in
kleineren wellen und fühle mich sehr gut
wäre ich noch eine woche zwei wochen
arbeit vor mir bis ich wieder 100
prozent bin
und dann hoffe ich das noch mal in
dieser saison richtig große wellen kommt
letzte frage herr steudtner wir haben
mit zu beginn der sendung über diesen
corona hotspot portugal berichtet jetzt
sind sie ja auch in portugal aktuell was
erleben sie dort in diesem land in dem
sich das du stark gewandelt hatte ich
war im vergangenen sommer selbst doch da
darf man nicht von corona überhaupt
nichts mitbekommen mittlerweile ist das
sozusagen der hotspot die hölle von
europa in sachen corona was kriegen sie
davon mit er ist krass wie schnell sich
das wandeln kann
als ich verletzt war im dezember war es
ja noch der der beste ort an dem man
sein konnte und als ich dann jetzt
zurückgekommen bin von der physio aus
deutschland ist im endeffekt alles
anders also jetzt ist eine sehr
angespannte stimmung würde ich sagen
müssen hier auf dem dorf das heißt es so
oder so sind weniger leute unterwegs und
dadurch dass sehr viele alte leute gibt
herrscht auch sehr viel respekt vor den
regeln
und jeder hält sich daran aber es ist
natürlich eine andere sehr andere
stimmung also ich gehe es auch nicht so
gern unnötig im supermarkt oder in
welche öffentlichen orte und habe das
glück dass das trainingszentrum hier
privat ist das heißt dass nur die surfer
reinkommen das wir getestet werden auch
und dass ich auf dem wasser sondern nur
mit meinem teamkollegen unterwegs bin
aber eher die stimmung ist nicht mehr so
wie noch im dezember oder im november
bastian steudtner dort nach mazar e zu
den monsterwellen wenn die nicht wären
würde ich wegen corona sagen ist das
meer im moment ein sicherer ort danke
ihnen passen sie gut auf sich auf
bleiben sie gesund